legal weed is turning New York workers
into zombies great so this is a New York
Post story let's see what they have to
say
so uh apparently uh let me see this
thing okay the decriminalization of
marijuana has led to widespread use
amongst service employees in New York
City resulting in lethargy disengagement
and forgetfulness hey can you remember
to put that in my schedule I got you
yeah yeah we can never in the calendar
minimum wage should be lowered since
many workers have become hopelessly
stunned at or dumb who said that by the
way let me know something on the minimum
kid now that's just a quote so there are
several examples of service employees
who were stoned up the Wazoo and unable
to perform their jobs including a
cashier who forgot to give change a
service that's worker that's a lost a
car and a restaurant server who lost the
credit card the acreage odor of
marijuana uh smoke is everywhere even in
Broadway theaters and subway cars
Progressive politicians are responsible
for throwing the city into trash by
decriminalizing marijuana and allowing
the widespread use of the drug amongst
service employees do you see that in New
York when you go there or not really I
smell it you smell it yeah so you're
happier in New York I have actually
never smoked weed in my life I've never
tried it swear to God I don't know
anything about this except my high
school friends who would act very
similarly to what they're describing
here you can't say that you have to
admit to everybody here on here on live
podcast promise you didn't inhale if you
live in New York you can uh lie detect
is that a thing you can lie yeah I
promise never in my life no no what I'm
saying is my point is more if you you
know if you're in New York if you're
around friends that are smoking weed
you're getting high I knew what they
were doing I wasn't around them oh okay
when I was 16 I was sitting at home with
a cast on my leg just trying to figure
out how to walk in it's funny when I'm
around the kids and the kids are like
Dad what smell is that so that's skunk
yeah it is it is what that is Adam what
are your thoughts about this you may be
looking at the story and you may say you
would support something like this if the
santis did this in Florida is that kind
of what you're thinking yeah well let me
tell you this story is such [__]
okay this is such [__] why because
the let me tell you something about
These Guys these cash registers These
Guys these Uber drivers
you think they're waiting for [__]
weed regulation to start smoking weed
yeah these guys have been hitting the
bong for decades yeah okay they're not
waiting for weed regulation to set and
be like finally I can smoke my weed it's
just True You're Nobody they're saying
smoking it no no regardless listen
nobody can say they can't smoke that
weed no one's saying that that they
can't do it behind closed doors right
this is legally oh they're gonna do it
no no regardless well let me ask you a
question if I'm if I'm building a
company and you got guys that are hey
I'm gonna take a smoke break they're
outside and I'll turn them you know they
come back in hey so Johnny how you doing
good man how you doing like I'm good so
you're gonna you're gonna finish that
video yeah yeah boss I got it okay
dude like
five o'clock you forgot he leaves and so
productivity doesn't go up there is no
I'm not saying that there's benefits
from doing it but the difference is
these guys are now smoking legally
there's a difference between they've
been smoking for a while you're right
but now you're getting into an Uber and
you're like this guy just smoked a joint
before me getting in here yeah here we
go we'll open the windows no it's cold
it's New York I fully agree with you
fully agree with you but what I'm saying
is yeah they're gonna do it regardless
whether it's legal whether it's illegal
where they can buy it on the street
where they can buy it from their drug
dealer they're gonna get if they want to
get high they're going to get high
they're not waiting for government
regulation to set it and be like finally
I can take myself can I tell everybody
what you're doing I know you're you know
how sometimes you're talking to me but
the audience doesn't know the
conversation we just had right before
the podcast yeah go ahead okay so here's
what Adam is requesting and I haven't
yet approved it Rob you know about this
this was a length you're gonna reveal
our private conversation are you okay
with it if I tell them that you know
what I'm a teacher wants us to do a
podcast smoking weed
not doing it he wants to do a live
podcast smoking I told you medium choice
between gummies cookies and the actual
tape like I'm smoking of the weed and
we're not doing it now if Adam wants to
do that it's a different story the
audience would like to see that I think
Oliver Stone wanted to do that we even
brought him away humidor we bought for
him I'm curious so what the chat if you
had to guess the percentage of what the
chat would say yes to Pat and
everybody's smoking weed or you don't
want me smoking what do you think it
would be what I I think it would be
I'm gonna go ahead and say this
Elizabeth the audience is gonna say 85
right okay I'm telling you it won't be
80 points come on guys and girls let me
say one question I have a feeling it's
gonna be
65. would you like to see pbd pbd smoke
weed what I'm telling it's gonna be 65
and Rogan if it's no no no no no no just
just us let's just see what they're
gonna say but go ahead yeah as much as
um it seems like I'm defending weed I I
I'm all I'm saying is These Guys these
guys are gonna be smoking it regardless
I will say that that you know you just
said regard you said regardless three
times okay what I thought about what
regard me you know what confused regard
me yeah have you seen Couples Retreat
seven years
regard me you don't know that guy the
reason why I know it's because I just
watch it with the kids this by the way
Couples Retreat what a movie that is
East Island you know what do they do
over there
[Laughter]
they're making it so strong these days
and I I totally can empathize with what
they're saying here lethargy
disengagement forgetfulness lethargy
wait one of me yeah
Adam has lethargy today and you make fun
of this ESL speaking guy and you got
like a 4.0 GPA knife
is that you say it like someone is
lethargic Okay I'm thinking of uh you
can never talk about that again
it's not lethargy no but go ahead
it's Adam's newest product is uh made
out of leather yeah if you're a leopard
with lethargy well I forgot my story I
forgot my thought over here
oh here's the story so I remember being
in college smoking weed for like first
time yeah and super stoned and uh now
it's even stronger the weed these days
and I remember being like all right I
gotta go to the store and I gotta buy
some stuff
so I remember I got in the car I opened
the car door
sat in the seat put my key in the
ignition and I was sitting in shotgun
[Laughter]
then out of the car walk around go into
the driver's seat the whole time I'm
thinking if anyone just saw me
could I just could I went through this
fast idiot I'm in the United States Air
Force six years only spoke a couple
times before because I have really
strict parents I get out first day I do
the Volcano Vaporizer for the people out
there that smoke you know what that is
Pat it's this big silver thing yeah it
feels it heats the weed like the Vapes
now it fills up a garbage bag I go I hit
the whole thing and I'm like let me
drive to Long Beach I'm gonna go to the
beach I'm gonna go have this thing right
here look at that bag it fills up so Pat
I hit it on the 405. I'm gone I'm only
20 miles an hour a cop pulls up in front
of me which is always you know I'm like
he's supposed to be back there the cop
turns on his lights and he starts doing
something called the traffic break which
you know what that is right Pat when the
cop turns on his lights and they start
swerving to slow down traffic I am so
high I just start following the cop I'm
like let me just start swerving now I'm
like are we in a computer
no no he's in front I'm following him do
this move oh he pulls over because
there's a bumper on the freeway he gets
out I get out and I follow him and I go
officer he's like I scared the [__] he's
like get the [__] back in your car he's
like what's your problem like I'm sorry
just and I got in the car
I was high as [__] never smoked after
that here you go finish no more weed to
bring this to to please you know so you
don't think we're all just pot after
Jackie yeah lethargic I'd like to know
what the kind of tax revenue that the
the state of New York or even the state
of California has actually received from
legalizing this because there is money
in this
a billion 300 million there you go
they're killing it bro yeah there's a
lot of money in weight 1.3 billion what
about New York
oh my god dude Massachusetts you less
how many lethargies come from all that
money it's permanently
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]